hey guys how's it going guess whose
birthday it is today
hey I'm unshowered Jenna I'm not
showered yet either but I need to make
the sangria because the sangria asked
you to chill for a while for two 24
hours and I'm a little bit late on me
not open mine yeah okay I'm good so
enjoy Olive Garden the other day and we
had sangria and it was incredible so I
was looking up ways to make all of
garden sangria Alexa how many
milliliters are in a leader 100 equals
1000 milliliters so we need like a
bottle and a half Wow how did you get
here so quickly I just got here
she just got here are you - okay yeah
it's beautiful it's perfect yeah you
really like it for one two tickets this
is like joke it's an inside joke I'll
explain it here in a second you I love
it it's incredible so I invited Jenna
Justine and a couple people over to my
apartment to watch the continent Gregor
and Nate Diaz fight and I was all
excited it was later that day and I
literally I could not wait and then
Jenna while I'm in the middle of making
a video text me and says hey I got
tickets to the adult concert two of them
for me and you you don't have to come
but I'm going regardless and I'm like
wait are you serious she's like yeah I'm
going no matter what and then I was with
Justine and Edie and then
like I need to find like a fake ticket
to send him just to be like I don't know
so he believed me and I find like the
worst fake ticket you can find so I got
a picture that basically all said was
this it was like a low quality like it
was like slay 20 pixels by 20 pixels
that was so tiny and grainy and it is
what you think think I use that exam
exam image for this cake I'm like I know
it's a little small but oh so we gotta
get back to the sangria though because
this has got a chill we tell them okay
is your refrigerator yeah okay so we've
got a problem this won't fit in the
fridge so we got to cut the board cut
the board cuts that board works nicely
you you might want you with that you
might want to blend some of these
berries together too - wow yeah this is
getting this is filling up and me with
it yeah we're not adding any extra sugar
that's fine if we said it was one and a
half this look Alexa how many
milliliters are on one and a half liters
one of the half liters is 1500
milliliters yeah we're good oh we are
Wow I'm drunk oh definitely add
sparkling water it is the 14 $99
personally awesome hahaha because I
always make jokes and I'm like I don't
know why it's just a really stupid joke
but it's my favorite drink
actually it's the Brandon yeah oh my
gosh
oh is it cuz I ever steal me thanks for
the recommendation you know when people
ask for suggestions I'm like my thing we
have just dived into the sangria what do
you think of it there's good luck not a
very tasty Olive Garden I love public
all darter has like mass production and
huge food corporations that its back
this was homemade I'm done homemade I
think there's comes pre-mixed if you
want some more I like a little bit more
okay Jenn here's your card I might have
got some food on it when hey Bobbi ready
music pretzel why I got it
hey hey happy birthday
how can I get away I'm sorry chef oh
gosh
Wilshire and I'm super excited because
we've always wanted to rent out the back
room today thing we decided that for
Jenna's birthday we were gonna be here
decide if there is enough what do you
guys be active ugh I feel like every
Moscow mules and who makes a better one
to Matt or the restaurant
wait wait but in my defense you did like
my meal a lot right I wasn't saying that
it wasn't no I wasn't saying the
restaurants guaranteed to be better I
was genuinely I know I thought the mule
was good as well and I never had one
before so I have nothing to compare it
to I don't know how are you hold on I'm
in the process of longing
I was about to wrong Matt yeah hey
what's up I just moved to California
hello California already supposed to ask
me that I was before we started the can
we ruin the blog no no you took the gun
by revealing the big news you did yeah
yeah so this my wife actually she's deep
in conversation Josh and Ashley are here
we're here and liquor so big news nice
hey guys love it should I send as a team
of the year oh yeah yeah it's a hangar
price Orellana available $5 pay palace
yeah they're here
got it cool we're gonna do another
cooking video we just decided um oh yeah
I'm free yeah no I'm trying to do I'm
trying to do all like I have one like
Fun Pack so I'm trying to do fake legs
made out of like novel material so I
feel like food would be
like imagine like a leg of Pancakes or a
leg of like burgers or a leg of like
cook like I don't know like a good a
watermelons I feel like could be a good
I was a side leg oh but like I haven't
done leg out but yeah I feel like Lego
is ago I feel like with Lego you can
make a really well-functioning like I
just found that tub of what's
essentially your entire body dissolved
into individual bricks so we have enough
flora money for like two legs a torso
two skinny weird arse and her head in a
weird way should we do it yeah don't
let's do it yeah that we also do like
joints it'll be like Lake shapes yeah a
cell phone a computer I was fifty
experience away from level 23 hit the
Hoka stop it's right here in this
restaurant and now we're 23 also I have
never seen a Tangela or tangible how are
you pronouncing on pokemons go here I
know what is it 2016 this is weird
it's instinct isolation ease up God's
too far away I can continue I'm tempted
actually right now because it's an
instinct jamming never so no it's
mystical god I think I'm going to don't
repeat it there should be a nice BMW
actually a lot of young Lena its mystic
now it was
dear
this is great I'm sorry very much we
still got one more time with Kate so
there's a cage no one this point you
guys have probably heard the story what
are you doing
it's the chat yes it's a real quick
please call me back
literally this was it a like 65 good
night got us tickets for a delta morrow
you don't have to go but i am 12 minutes
please well I think it turning yeah
because I was a little one recording and
we just came in like the time in between
text and and then the image comes in
here just you see with an ad you do it
you probably the one person I would
trust like this my good god don't slice
your finger you're running the fonda
that's what they call it
I made that nut cake expert don't worry
you can sleep on it right now okay are
you supposed to eat the way I only I pan
and Zach house now you're ready the hall
right here sit
hey wait I'm a DJ kana DJ good good sit
bring the bell Oh both roll the belly
the Bell patty that's good no I'm sure
it fit ring the bell ring the bell ring
the bell ring the bell good boy it was
funny he was really hungry now you
actually think this right up on you I'm
sick
high five it's going right down up sit
down for a minute you remember that time
you spilled marinara sauce on my knees
yeah really belly oh my gosh Bob sit
high five up lay down up hey sit up high
five later Marvis good morning everyone
so this is the morning after of the
party that we weren't supposed to have
Jenna specifically said I do not want a
party especially after math birthday
party at a little extra while I'm
drinking coffee and I'm not even sure if
this is will this video be even long
enough for a vlog I don't know sorry if
it's not long enough no more parties it
wasn't a party not a joke it's Connie
rap mmm oh speaking a joke it's very
serious to me
one of the camera yeah what you're like
out there no I have you in the shot
do you hear so it ten millimeter lens
Brut wide okay bye
how she's going to absolutely love it
have a holly jolly Christmas